maryanne as well as Marianne's in Boise
Idaho hi Marianne how are you hi Dave
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up well my husband and I own
our own business our business requires
us to drive quite a bit and we both are
driving big gas guzzler cars we have to
go into debt to trade out one of our
cars and and even to buy oh stop stop
stop stop stop
what what is your big guest clothes are
worth not a lot well I have a 2003 Chevy
Trailblazer that's worth only yeah I'd
say five thousand at the most and you're
driving a five thousand dollar car now
why could you not drive drive a five
thousand dollar car that wasn't a gas
guzzler well that's the whole thing of
the fear that I have of getting another
used car and not sure how it's been
maintained if it's going to have
problems I know my car's been maintained
meticulously yeah you're driving a car
with a lot of miles on it yeah I don't
care I meticulously it's been maintained
yes and so you know to get a comparable
car that gets good gas mileage oh you're
getting ready tell me you had to get a
comparable car to your car you have to
go into debt that's ridiculous
think yeah I think you think you're the
only person on a planet that
meticulously maintains a car that's
worth $5,000 no okay so you say well
except I don't accept your
presupposition here that this requires
debt for you to get a reliable car
you're driving a car that's reliable it
just happens to have a gas guzzling how
many miles are you driving uh between 50
and 70 a day so what does your gas bill
run like well my husband drives a big
bigger gas guzzler
they truck what's his batteries we spend
between five and six hundred a month
okay I'm sorry if you cut it in half
it's 250 a month yes yeah okay that's
nice and what's your household income
well we just started this business about
a year and a half ago and basically
we're still running in the red
how are you eating savings
crud yeah all right that we're trying so
when is the business going to be
profitable well we thought it would be
by now and that's why I'm looking at
what can we cut what is still so high
and that's eating into our what do you
what is your monthly expenditures now
what's it taking month to stay afloat
hmm I mean personally or for the
business I guess the whole thing because
you're having to write the checks for
all of it yeah I would say 2,500 a month
yeah okay well this is ten percent of
your problem and I'm not going into debt
to solve any problem but I'm certainly
not for 10 percent of your problem just
earn $50 a month is the gas savings if
you say both of them now what's his
truck worth well he won't sell his truck
he have to go get another something on
the side he's got a 2003 GMC pickup that
he spent fifty five thousand for and
it's only worth about twelve so he will
never sell that okay
say I don't think I can help you because
you know you've got all these false
parameters in your life that aren't real
he will never sell his truck but you're
willing to sell your car and go into
debt for a car another used car you know
this is just you're just you're out
there too far seriously I don't think I
can reel you back in thank you for the
call though
you